when your mom picks you up gets you out
of baltimore sends you to um school of
arts yeah you meet tupac shakur no i met
tupac at baltimore school for the arts
we went to high school together and you
you you were very close with tupac
shakur yes and tupac shakur wasn't the
gangster that we all think he was right
i remember his mother was a black
panther yes and he had a lot of uh black
panthers sort of raised by the black
panthers and all that
uh but he was a revolutionary without a
revolution if that makes any kind of
sense so then that and that that kind of
energy just transferred to
a whole nother whole nother thing and
don't you believe at that time he was in
love with you because he would write
poetry about you you know i think
it's so funny because now being older i
i have more of an understanding of of of
what that was between us because you
know when you have two young people have
very strong feelings but there's no
physical chemistry between us at all and
it wasn't even just for me right you
know it was him too i mean don't i mean
you know there was a time when i was
like just kiss me let's just see how
this goes and when i tell you it had to
be the most
disgusting
kiss for us both explain that to me
because it was so platonic the
relationship i think you know
the only way i can put it is just the
higher power just did not want that
because i feel as though if pock and i
had any kind of sexual chemistry we
might have killed each other because we
were both so passionate
and you know
we we loved deeply i mean it was hard
enough just with us being friends we had
a very uh volatile relationship um did
you recognize him as a great talent at
that i did i did what was it his poetry
it was his poetry it was his personality
i had never in my life
uh
met a
person charisma he had so much charisma
and he didn't he was
he was poor i mean poc was poor when i
met poc he owned two pairs of pants and
two sweaters and that's it were you
shocked when he achieved the degree of
fame that he did absolutely not really i
knew that was gonna happen i mean for
both of you to become famous out of this
shitty neighborhood in baltimore is
almost impossible it is it's crazy and
he used to tell me all the time he was
like jada you're a superstar he's like
you're a superstar he didn't say it
about himself he didn't say it about
himself no he didn't but he used to say
it about me and i you know
and he went to la and no he went to um
oakland he went up north and things
started jumping off for him and it it
really happened for us both at the same
time but then as you go off to la and
pursue a career and he goes off doing
his thing you guys
are not friends he he went to jail he
went to jail and you've you've said when
he went to jail for the first time
he called you after that
and that he changed jail changed him
well it wasn't
there was there was a lot of things that
transpired once he went to jail it was
really once he came out right that he
you know he he changed quite a bit which
is understanding them or just coming out
of jail no no no no jail jail jail was
was uh
was a very
uh difficult experience for him and um
and of course we were on two sides of
the of the spectrum and you know
park and i have always had
very intense conversations
uh arguments and you know if we disagree
with each other we disagree hardcore and
we had a very hardcore disagreement and
what was the disagreement what was the
what was the thing that broke you guys
up in terms of a friendship um i just
wasn't in agreement with the direction
that he was taking and i just told him
that
you know
it was a destructive direction scary
scary a very scary direction and and he
felt as though you know i had changed i
got hollywood uh you know right and you
were gone
right and i understood all that you know
and looking back now i totally
understand
where poc was because at that particular
point in time that mentality was part of
his survival for that moment and it was
actually a mentality he started to come
out of before he was murdered right and
and so you hadn't spoken to him for a
couple of years and and the point i'm
getting at is that when he was murdered
you probably felt a lot of guilt that
you hadn't been in touch yes or were you
guilt-free because you said to yourself
well listen i couldn't go in that
direction i didn't want to be friends
with someone who was getting so hardcore
angry you know
i don't think i was guilty as much as i
felt
just sadness you know for not having
you know just the opportunity to tell
him that i loved him
but
i know he knew that you know because it
wasn't the first time that we had had a
bad argument and had stopped speaking
and all that i mean that was kind of a
constant in our relationship so i didn't
really look at it as
um
you know a reason to feel guilty but i i
it definitely taught me a lesson which
is
life is too short
do not is like
do not let disagreement stand in between
you and people that you love and care
about i can tell you're really emotional
about him i mean you're crying i mean
when you think of him you have tears in
your eyes you know i love him yeah
yeah a terrible ending it was really
tragic but you know what he left a very
strong and powerful mark i mean people
are still
um you know inspired by him so he did
his work
you